make some noise for hip-hop history
this was the moment dave chappelle on
the stage of the hollywood bowl was
attacked by a man who rushed from the
audience filmed by someone in the crowd
he's thrown to the ground all of it
during a netflix comedy festival
police say 23 year old isaiah lee has
been charged with assault with a deadly
weapon they say he was armed with a
replica gun that could eject knife
blades i think what was surprising was
that it it happened so easily at like
such a major venue that is known for
having like huge names and um events
what was very surreal was he had you
know minutes before this talked about
having more security on stage because of
like what was happening
with comedians
it comes after the backlash to
chappelle's netflix special last year
the comic branded anti-semitic and
anti-trans for his routine and netflix
facing a walkout and protests by its own
staff the star was performing in london
as the controversy erupted netflix
standing by him despite the wave of
anger from employees and activists
and the incident comes so soon after
will smith slapped comedian chris rock
on stage during the oscars that opened a
debate about the safety of comedians at
work and the limits of free speech our
job is very simple when it comes down to
it is there's a group of people in front
of you no matter what size or where
they're from your job is to make them
laugh and it's never to hurt them or to
let them leave the gig or the show
feeling uncomfortable
or miserable that's the opposite of what
our intent is
the hollywood bowl says it's begun an
investigation into the incident dave
chappelle was uninjured the motive of
the attacker is currently unclear but it
is another high profile moment in the
debate that continues to grow over
whether comedy can go too far and when
it becomes no longer a laughing matter
greg milam sky news los angeles
[Music]